lizzo's out here making news
[Music]
that's lizzo feeling good as hell making
her red carpet debut with boyfriend mike
wright i'm feeling good as hell
over the weekend the singer hit the red
carpet for an fyc screening of her prime
video series watch out for the big girls
she posted a couple of snaps at the
event posing alongside her new flame and
other attendees including the real alum
lonnie love
photos
[Music]
but it was pics of lizzo and her new bow
that the internet can't get enough of
specifically this one her pink gloved
hand on top of his showcasing a diamond
ring on that finger
but we'll wait for the grammy winner to
announce when things are officially
official you'll remember back when lizzo
celebrated her 34th birthday in april
she was snap dressed to the nines and
holding hands with a mystery man at
craig's in la the same man she spent
valentine's day with at the hollywood
hot spot fans online were sent into a
frenzy over who her guy could possibly
be all the rumors are true yeah but you
heard that's true yeah turns out he's
comedian and actor mike wright you gotta
have dreams
that's why i hate celebrity kids cause
celebrity kids have already accomplished
your dreams
just by being born we saw mike and lizzo
again in april when he accompanied her
to an snl after party after she hosted
and performed on the show you truly
can't manifest your reality lizzo first
confirmed she was officially off the
market during an april episode of
siriusxm's andy cohen live you were
photographed in la in february at craigs
with a mystery man are you guys still
together
[Laughter]
yeah whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah
whatever was that person at snl to see
you
damn you're really good at this this is
what
and when asked what it's like to date
when you are incredibly successful lizzo
explained if you have the right person
it's not even a factor that's great yeah
because because it should be mutually
supportive yeah no matter what that
person does and we love seeing the
grammy winner in love because in 2019
she told e.t she was still figuring out
what she wanted nobody tried to holla at
me before all day so if you're trying to
hire me now i don't trust it yeah it's
got to be something real about you or
like you just got to be fine as hell
everybody wants you everybody want to
smash everybody want to be your best
friend so it's like really hard to kind
of siphon through like the
find the real people so cheers to lizzo
who's looking happy as hell with her new
man
[Music]